the Antarctic Peninsula is heating up
almost four times faster than the global
average warming oceans and air
temperatures are accelerating the ice
melt on land and water and new data
shows sea ice around the entire
continent has reached a record low this
year and there's still another few weeks
of the summer left in the southern
hemisphere
take a look at the latest satellite
mapping of Antarctica the Orange Line
shows the long-term average for sea ice
at this time of year and this was the
ice earlier this week the scale shows a
lot of what's left is patchy turn that
into a chart and you can see the sea ice
melts through the summer until the
beginning of March this is the average
with some variation from year to year
the previous record low was last summer
and this is the situation now the record
beaten and it's a similar story in the
Arctic winter should be a time when the
sea freezes over but this year it covers
a much smaller area than normal
particularly in the north of Europe
there's the UK and Scandinavia for much
of the winter the extent of the sea ice
has been tracking below average and the
previous record low set in March 2012
north and south sea ice is shrinking
that has a big impact on Polar animals
that depend on sea ice for rest shelter
and food but sea ice also drives Global
ocean currents and weather patterns and
scientists returning from Antarctica
warm the loss will affect us all one of
the interesting things about sea ice is
when it forms it releases salt in the
ocean and salt makes that water heavier
so it sinks it's one of the driving
forces of the conveyor belt so the Gulf
Stream that goes past our Shores is
actually driven by what happens in the
Antarctic as well as what happens in the
Arctic itself ditto with the with the
jet stream the jet stream is affected by
what happens in the polar regions and
therefore those meanders that we saw if
you think of the Arctic the beasts from
the East that was all driven by what's
happening in the Arctic
sea ice has been shrinking in the Arctic
for the last four decades the shift in
the Antarctic is much more recent but it
is dramatic and scientists don't fully
understand why it's happening now
Thomas More Sky News